hi thanks for joining me i'm angela
rasmussen
at the center for infection and immunity
at the columbia university mailman
school of public health
i'm a virologist who studies the host
response to viral infection
today i'm going to be talking about how
i do that
and what those host responses to virus
infection are and what they can tell us
before i get started i always like to do
a territorial acknowledgement and equity
statement
that today i'm presenting from the
unseated ancestral homelands of the
duwamish people
much of the analytical work presented
today was performed on the traditional
lands of both the duwamish people and
the lenape people
and i honor and acknowledge these first
people of these territories as well as
their tribal governments histories and
ancestry
and their roles today and caring for
these lands and i'd also like to
acknowledge the history of systemic
inequity in academic science that has
spanned decades and even centuries
columbia university was founded using
profits from the transatlantic slave
trade
which has left a very long and painful
legacy of racial and gender-based
inequities that continue to this day in
academic research and medicine
and i encourage all of you watching this
presentation to consider how you can
contribute
to making scientific research a more
equitable enterprise
so today i'm going to talk to you about
the host response to viral infection but
first i'm going to tell you a little bit
about
the systems biology approach that i use
to study this topic
and this is really an iterative process
in which i take experimental
data from experimental models in the lab
doing traditional virology biochemistry
and bench science and this can be in
either cell culture or animals
and applying that to various omics
techniques so these are
methods of looking at the entire
global host response to infection either
by looking at the transcriptome
measuring gene expression or by looking
at the proteome or metabolome
using mass spectrometry i take these
large data sets
and i apply them to computational models
bioinformatic methods of trying to sift
through
all of this data and find out what's
most important of it
from that i can get some clues to some
translational applications either
biomarker panels
that can be used to diagnose disease or
predict outcome
novel host directed drug targets as well
as correlates to protection for vaccines
then i can use the same models and the
same approach to test these over again
so this combination of multiple
experimental systems has been very
useful to answer complex questions
such as those involving the host
response that involve a lot of different
key players in the host in terms of
determining
either pathogenicity that's severity of
disease
or protection so one thing that's
important to understand about
pathogenesis is there's really two sides
to it
on one side we have the virus and
viruses are
they're not simple but they're
relatively um simple compared to human
hosts so they have smaller genomes that
encode fewer genes
in this case we're looking at ebola
virus these genes encode multifunctional
proteins
the human host by contrast has a much
larger genome size so 3.2 billion base
pairs
that encode roughly 20 000 different
genes and these genes are not only
multifunctional proteins but they can be
expressed as multiple isoforms and
they're organized into specialized
pathways
so there's this really complicated
interplay between a host and its
pathogen
that often determines how severe disease
can be
and we know from prior experiments that
these host responses are linked to
pathogenicity
or the ability of a virus to cause
disease on the left here
in this heat map we're looking at some
of the immune and inflammatory genes
that are expressed when
infected with a seasonal influenza virus
isolate um that's the texas
panel uh compared to a highly pathogenic
avian influenza isolate that's the h5n1
uh vietnam 1203 strain on the right and
as you can see
red on this map shows genes that are
incredibly upregulated you can see that
all of these inflammatory genes
are dramatically upregulated compared in
the
h5n1 compared to the seasonal influenza
virus
so we know that these different host
responses are associated with viruses
that cause disease of different severity
we see the same thing in the heat map on
the right looking at responses between
ebola virus which causes very severe
disease in people
versus rust and virus which is another
type of ebola virus that doesn't cause
disease in people at all
and again we see very different
characteristics of the host response to
these two viruses
so we know that these are these host
responses are linked to
disease severity so how do we study that
one way of doing this is by looking at
animal models of pathogenesis
so many people like different types of
animal models and they all have
different
advantages and disadvantages on the left
we have the inbred laboratory mouse
which has been a mainstay of scientific
research for the last 50 years
these animals are genotyped we know
their genomes we know what all of their
genes are we know what they do
they're highly homozygous meaning
they're not very genetically diverse
which means that they're very
reproducible
there are many reagents available for
interrogating their immune systems
they're small and easy to handle and
they're also affordable
the downside to this model is that
they're not very genetically diverse
which is very different from humans
they're also genetically distant from
humans they're not closely related to us
evolutionarily
there's poor correlation with host
response data in humans
when you look at uh host response data
from ice
and it often requires a human pathogen
to be adapted to replicate efficiently
in mice
so you actually have to use different
viruses in many cases
on the right we have non-human primates
most commonly the rhesus macaque
is used to study virus pathogenesis
these are genetically much closer to
humans and they're highly genetically
diverse
they're also susceptible to infection
with wild type human pathogens in many
cases but
disadvantage that they're not genotyped
they're exposed
there's limited reagents to look at
their immune systems and they're also
much larger
which can be a problem when you're
working with highly pathogenic viruses
that require
higher levels of biocontainment
furthermore
in 2013 a study was done that showed
that
host response data from mice from c57
black six mice
did not replicate or did not correlate
at least with host response data from
human diseases for a number of different
inflammatory conditions
including infection so for this reason
people thought that that mice may not be
the best model for
looking at host responses and mouse
adapted ebola virus
um there is a mouse model for ebola and
it uses a mouse adapted virus
is of limited utility in these lab mice
so when you infect
lab mice with wild type uh ebola
in this case the myangus strain which is
the prototypic strain of ebola
there is some virus replication but it
doesn't cause disease and it doesn't
kill the animals when
you use the mouse zapped virus it does
kill the animals however the disease is
not very similar to what you see in
human ebola virus disease
so we wanted to know if increased host
genetic diversity would result in an
expanded range of these host responses
and allow us to better model
this disease in pathogenesis and its
pathogenesis
so we began using the collaborative
cross mouse systems genetics model
this model uh incorporates over 90
percent of the genetic diversity across
the entire mus musculus species
and that's compared with conventional
inbred laboratory mice which only
encompass about 11 of that genetic
diversity
this is a panel of mice that are
generated through this funnel breeding
scheme
that's the result of crossing eight
different mouse genetic backgrounds
together
five of these are conventional
laboratory mice and three of them are
wild mice derived
after this this breeding scheme these
multiple funnels will result
in a panel of mice that are reproducible
and
inbred but are genetically distinct from
one another
and have expanded genetic diversity
we decided to try to model ebola virus
disease using this model
so modelling ebola virus disease is very
complicated um
ebola virus infects a number of
different cell types and it has effects
on other cell types that it does not
infect
so when a person is infected with ebola
virus the first targets are monocytes
and macrophages
as well as neutrophils these these cells
will be
infected they will migrate to secondary
lymphoid organs
and they will begin secreting
pro-inflammatory cytokines
they will also begin secreting large
amounts of virus this causes
lymphocytes cd4 t cells cd8 t cells and
b cells in those secondary lymphoid
organs to undergo bystander apoptosis
at the same time the viremia that
results from all this virus secretion
causes the hepatocytes in the liver to
become infected
causing those cells to die and depleting
the blood of clotting factors
the pro-inflammatory cytokines that are
secreted into the bloodstream
cause disseminated intravascular
intravascular coagulation to occur
and this results in the coagulopathy
and prolonged coagulation and vascular
leakage
that is characteristic of hemorrhagic
ebola virus disease
so this is a complex disease that
requires multiple cell types
of to model pathogenesis so you need to
have a model that is going to
encapsulate all of these different
complex factors
and what we saw when we infected
collaborative cross mice
with mouse adapted ebola virus is that
we saw
a dependency of severity by genetic
background
so we saw some mice that had an expanded
range
of disease phenotypes or presentations
in some mice they died
similar to what conventional laboratory
mice do
some mice died with evidence of
hemorrhagic syndrome
and some mice were what we call tolerant
which means that they were infected with
the virus they had a relatively mild
course of disease from which they fully
recovered
you can see the differences here in this
uh in this slide
on the left we have survival and
morbidity data as measured by weight
loss you see that all of the lethal
hemorrhagic syndrome lines
uh died by day six post-infection
um both lines lost weight at the same
rate
but you can see that the tolerant
animals shown in blue recovered
after 14 days you also see that in the
animal that was susceptible to lethal
disease with hemorrhagic syndrome that
there was prolonged clotting times as
well as
reduced serum fibrinogen and both of
these animals had virus replicating in
the liver this is a immunohistochemistry
slide
showing vp40 which is a viral protein
in the animal with lethal disease there
was significantly more virus than in the
tolerant animal
so as i mentioned we can see a spectrum
of different ebola virus disease
phenotypes in the collaborative cross
and both in cc lines and cc rix lines
which are
crossed between two collaborative cross
lines you see about a third of the
animals are tolerant
a third of them have lethal disease with
no hemorrhagic syndrome
and a third of them have lethal disease
with hemorrhagic syndrome in the 75
lines that we've looked at so far
so this model is definitely better and
it's an improvement upon the
existing inbred animal model in inbred
mouse models for studying ebola virus
disease
next um we're comparing tolerance versus
susceptibility
so this is how does the host response
differ in tolerant animals versus
susceptible ones
this is a really important question
since as i mentioned before
the host response can determine disease
severity
so we know that tolerant animals are
infected as i mentioned before as well
but they restrict production of
infectious virus and that's what this
slide shows
so we see that both this in the spleen
and liver which are susceptible organs
to ebola virus infection
we see increases in viral rna there are
only significant differences however
in uh in when you look at infectious
virus by focus forming assay which looks
at virus that is actually capable of
infecting and replicating in
cells um we see that the lethal animals
have significantly more infectious virus
that has been produced in both organs
compared to the tolerant animals
so again this suggests that while virus
in virus infection is part of the story
it's not the entire story there's still
probably host specific differences that
are determining
uh the difference in outcome
so we looked at the transcriptomes of
these animals this is looking at gene
expression across the entire genome
over time after infection in four lethal
uh collaborative cross lines compared to
six
tolerant collaborative cross lines and
what we saw is that lethal outcomes are
associated with very early suppression
of the host response in general
as you can see on both of these heat
maps for the spleen on the left and the
liver on the right
there is a big gray stripe uh on the
lethal side of things
at day one post infection and that
really shows that all of these host
responses
are are inhibited or they're just really
not the host isn't responding to
infection
early on whereas in the tolerant animals
at day one you do see
either blue for inhibition or red for up
regulation
of many of these different host pathways
and if you look at the slide closely
you can see that many of these pathways
are involved in immune and inflammatory
responses
suggesting that tolerance is associated
with a very early
immune response to virus infection
we looked more closely at functional
enrichment and we saw that early
suppression of host immunity does drive
this tolerant phenotype
or lethal phenotype again you can see it
day three post infection
and this is a combination of the the
genes that are expressed as well as
micro rnas
which regulate those genes being
expressed that there is a profound
suppression
of um immune and inflammatory responses
in lethal animals at day three
compared to tolerant animals in which
many of these are
upregulated key thing to note is that
many of these things at later time
points are actually down regulated
intolerant animals which suggests that
while lethal animals have no
early response the early response
intolerant animals
allows them to better regulate these
responses
it's thought that severe ebola virus
disease is caused by
unregulated expression of these innate
immune
and inflammatory factors that cause a
systemic inflammatory condition to occur
in the tolerant animals those early
responses allow that response to be
controlled
whereas in the lethal case those
controls are completely removed
and so there's later a complete
unregulated up regulation of
inflammation
which causes disease now i'm going to
switch gears a little bit and talk about
how we can use these host responses to
predict disease outcome so we already
know which
which of these host responses are
associated with either tolerance or
lethality
is there any way that we could use this
information to predict
outcome including in patients and the
way we decided to approach this was
using a machine
learning approach called random forests
random forests are a binary decision
tree method
of classification that allows you to
take
gene profiles and and build a model
that can discriminate on either a lethal
or a tolerant outcome
using those gene expression profiles
when we did this random forest method
with a
profile of about 14 genes from spleen or
liver
and collaborative cross mice we got
extremely high accuracy of
classification
meaning that we were able to predict
99.9 percent of times
uh the correct outcome in using data
from the spleen
and correctly 99.6 percent of times
in the liver and these were done by
re-running this
over a thousand times to uh to see how
many times we could get it right
so how does the classifier trained in
mice compare to patient data
this is the really relevant question if
we want to try to apply
our findings from the collaborative
cross mouse model to
human ebola virus disease patients we
were able to
obtain sequence uh transcriptomic data
from
ebola virus disease patients from west
africa
this study used a similar approach
random force and another machine
learning algorithm called support vector
machines
to also do similar predictions and they
were able to classify
outcome correctly 79 to 85 percent of
the time
we wanted to know if we could take the
genes that we had identified in mice
apply it to the patients and see similar
prediction performance
we were able to accurately predict the
outcome in both
mouse and human data sets so on the left
this is a receiver operating
characteristic curve
that shows the accuracy of this
classification approach
on the left we have the human data used
to predict
outcome in the mice we were able to
predict
correctly the outcome in the mice 90.5
percent of the time that's what that auc
number indicates that's the area under
the curve
um on the right we have the mouse clas
the mouse trained classifier
tested on the ebola virus disease human
patient set
and in this case we were able to predict
outcome correctly 75
of the time it's still not as robust as
in the mice
um however it's similar to what they
found using the human data alone to
predict
outcome using the human data set which
indicates that this approach is
promising
we then took this data and
we enhanced this by developing a
classifier using
ebola data from non-human primates this
was a non-human primate model of the
mekona ebola isolate that caused the
west african epidemic
once we added the non-human primate data
to our model we were able to predict
outcome correctly 95.6 percent of the
time
again showing that with additional data
from multiple models
despite the complexity of the host
response we were able to
uh correctly predict outcome in a
majority of patients
using this method this strongly suggests
that we may be able to
apply data that we learn
we might be able to apply findings about
the host response obtained from animal
models
to accurately predict a human disease
which
has applications for both diagnostics
and prognostics
so there are other zoonotic pathogens
that are being modeled in the
collaborative cross
um that produce similarly diverse
phenotypes
so this has broader applications beyond
just ebola virus disease
here we have data from four different
pathogens
on the upper left we have a strain of
influenza called pr8 that causes disease
in mice
and is used to model influenza virus
disease
in in mouse models and we see here a
distribution of different
phenotypes regarding weight loss and
airway inflammation
across multiple collaborative cross
genetic backgrounds
on the right we have sars coronavirus
again we see a similar distribution of
different disease
phenotypes on the lower left we see west
nile virus
which causes both a tolerant phenotype
it causes acute disease in collaborative
cross backgrounds
and it also can cause a chronic or
persistent infection in these
backgrounds again simulating the
spread of different disease
presentations that we see with west nile
virus infection in people
and on the lower right we have tyler's
murine encephalitis virus
which is a mouse virus that is often
used to
model uh neurotropic virus infection
and again we see a different spread of
different phenotypes
that are based on collaborative cross
genetic background
so this may be very useful for studying
other emerging viruses
um here i have some data that is
actually unpublished
that was generated for a grant
application that shows that we see a
similar spread
of lethality and tolerance as well as
partial tolerance
and collaborative cross mice that are
infected with both h1n1 the 1918
pandemic strain
as well as the highly pathogenic vietnam
1203
isolate of h5n1 avian influenza
again we are seeing this this broader
spread
of uh different phenotypes in this
genetically diverse mouse model
suggesting that it might be good for for
modeling the various types of host
responses that we see
in people we've also obtained similar
data
modeling different dengue virus outcomes
in the collaborative cross
so this really suggests that this model
may be very good and very useful
for understanding emerging viruses
that we don't have very much information
on with regards to the host response and
that it can faithfully replicate
many different disease presentations
that we see in humans
and this is an ongoing active area of
research
so there are a number of host response
questions that we can address
using the collaborative cross model
including applications to stars
virus ii which i'm going to end by
speaking briefly about
we can map genes associated with disease
severity because the collaborative cross
is fully
sequenced and we know all of the genomic
differences for the various
collaborative cross lines that are
available
this model is excellent for linking
genes
statistically to various complex traits
or phenotypes different disease
presentations
we can also more closely investigate the
role of non-coding rna in the host
response which is something that
is really poorly understood currently
we can also look at the gene expression
responses and individual cell types
from different tissues so that we can
start looking at cell type specific host
responses
we can investigate mechanisms of
pathogenesis once these models have been
established
we can do transmission or infection root
studies
to understand how susceptible an animal
or a person would be by a given
infection root
we can look at persistence which is
something that is an
open question for stars coronavirus 2
it's something that has only been
appreciated for many other acute viral
infections such as ebola
in recent years when there's been
evidence of persistence in human
patients
and finally we can use these models to
test novel drugs vaccines and
diagnostics
something that again is of critical
importance given the ongoing sars
coronavirus 2
covet 19 pandemic
so as promised i'm going to end by
speaking briefly
about some efforts that i have planned
with collaborators to model sars
coronavirus 2 in the collaborative cross
model
so one thing that's important to note is
that sars coronavirus 2 the wild type
virus cannot use mouse ace2 as a
receptor
ace2 is the molecule that the virus has
to bind in order to enter the cell and
cause an infection
there are transgenic mice that express
the human ac2 receptor
and they can be infected but they do not
develop severe disease or at least they
develop severe disease in a background
dependent model
that suggests that a genetically diverse
model such as the collaborative cross
might actually be much more appropriate
now ace2 human ace2 is located on the x
chromosome this is important because
human ace2 transgenic mice are what are
called nokian mice that means that ace2
the human ace2 transgene has been
inserted
and replaces the mouse gene for ace two
that's on the x chromosome
this also means that if you crossed a
collaborative cross mouse
with an a human ace2 transgenic nokian
mouse
all of the offspring would be able to
express eight ace two
because they all have an x chromosome
so we are planning to make what are
called f1
human ace2 transgenic collaborative
cross mice
this is where we take a female ace2
transgenic mouse which will have a copy
of the human ace2 on each x chromosome
and we cross these with male
collaborative cross mice
those offspring will both have the
genetic diversity
present in the collaborative cross and
will also express
human ace too thus rendering them
susceptible to sars coronavirus ii
infection
our plan is to use this model to look at
the diverse array of host responses
in different genetic backgrounds and
determine how this relates to disease
pathogenesis
and covid19 severity
so finally i'd like to acknowledge my
many collaborators without whom this
work
would not have been possible as well as
my funding sponsors
and i'm happy to answer any questions
that are sent to me after this talk
thank you so much for your time and
attention